my god
what incredibility of news oh wow happy
April Fool's isn't that Christmas oh
yeah oh well I thought I'd roll the
Internet with ridiculous stories that
will never come true isn't that a bit
mean oh yeah but publishers do it all
the time that's true but instead why not
do a video about all the April Fool's
stories and games that did come true you
you the ideas fairy yes
when voice actor David Hayter posted a
lengthy tweet that he'd not been asked
to reprise his role as beleaguered
mercenary snake in Metal Gear Solid 5
gamers laughed it off as a harmless
April Fool's Day prank
he's been voicing the character for 15
years we said surely he's joshing well
apparently not as a few weeks later
Konami announced that he'd been dumped
in favor of Hollywood actor and general
lost boy Kiefer Sutherland it was a
banner year for fools fans in 2013 as
Ubisoft released a teaser trailer and
distinctly neon infused website for a
far cry spin-off called Blood Dragon
look at them getting into the spirit we
laughed but then a couple of weeks later
lo and behold the official announcement
dropped revealing that Blood Dragon was
actually a badass standalone piece of
content with Michael buying from alien
and Dragons that shoot lasers out of
their eyes
professional trolls and occasional game
makers valve got into the spirit in 2009
revealing via a blog post on the
official Team Fortress 2 website that
there was a new weapon for the sniper
class Jarett a jar based karate aka HRP
it was actually released the following
month and when thrown at an enemy they
take more damage for a short amount of
time and it can even uncloak spies
because you know they're covered in pee
so I guess if you get hit by jarate
you're in trouble sorry
Blizzard the kings and queens of gaming
pranks have come up with
number of classics over the years like
the infamous tinfoil hat a response to
Warcraft players who were getting a
little too paranoid about the impending
release of the WoW armory
that was also Blizzard outcasts a fake
fighting game pitting some of the
developers lesser known characters
against each other but it's 2002 is
offering that takes the cake artists
summarized idea created a peaceful race
of pandas for April Fool's Day the
Pandaren got a more positive reaction
than expected and soon panda escapades
were being written into Warcraft slaw
rumors were a band that they were being
introduced as a new alliance race and
after playing long game in 2011 Blizzard
officially announced them as a playable
race for the mists of pandaria expansion
I guess they were pandering to their
audience huh I'm here all week see don't
you feel like you've done a good thing
reassuring the internet that they didn't
fear April Fool's Day and sometimes
dreams do come true well but only
because I had two minutes if I could
have done a video about all the gaming
April fools that didn't come true we'd
be here until next week but still
imagine if Kojima did join One Direction